beaucoup à tous d'être là nous sommes un
petit peu en comité restreint ce soir
mais la commission des Affaires
économique travaillera jusqu'au bout et
même au-delà voilà mes chers collègues
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir ce
soir Agnès urinaché Ministre chargé la
transition énergétique au cas où vous ne
la reconnaîtriez pas
pour échanger avec elle sur l'actualité
du secteur de l'énergie en 2019 le Sénat
et l'Assemblée nationale dans le cadre
de la loi énergie climat ont adopté le
principe d'une loi quinquennale sur
l'énergie je vous le rappelle cette loi
doit fixer les objectifs et les moyens
de notre politique énergétique nationale
elle doit prévaloir sur les documents
réglementaires qu'ils soient pris en
application du droit national comme la
PPA ou la stratégie nationale bas
carbone ou du droit européen comme les
plans nationaux intégrés en matière
d'énergie et de climat avec cette loi
quinquennale l'objectif du législateur a
été en de replacer le Parlement au cœur
de la transition énergétique en faisant
prévaloir la loi sur le règlement et la
politique sur la technique selon
l'article elle sentirait un du code de
l'énergie le premier exercice de cette
loi quinquennale devait intervenir je
cite avant le premier juillet 2023
c'était science légale connue depuis
2019 n'est donc pas tenu et à la place
le gouvernement a multiplié les textes
sectoriels sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement pas tout à fait
inutile mais quand même les énergies
renouvelables l'énergie nucléaire ou les
récemment les industries vertes nous
avons légiféré vous le savez on aime
bien cette expressions dans le désordre
en fixant les modalités avant les
objectifs il manque au total une
stratégie d'ensemble pour favoriser les
décisions d'investissement le désordre
est tel que l'on retrouve même plusieurs
souplesse administratives dans
différents vecteurs législatifs 3
dérogations aux opérations d'aménagement
la loi littorale à la Directive Habitat
par exemple une vigilance doit s'imposer
pour que l'application ne se disposition
soit tout à fait effective et cohérente
mesdames la ministre mes questions
introductives sont assez directes qu'en
pensez-vous que le gouvernement pourra
présenter au Parlement le projet de loi
quinquennale sur l'énergie peut-être
pouvez-vous nous expliquer pourquoi nous
sommes un petit peu en retard surtout
quel sera le contenu de ce projet de loi
quinquennal je rappelle que l'article
précédait du code de l'énergie a prévu 6
objectifs de réduction des émissions de
diminutions des consommations de
développement des EnR de diversification
du mix électrique de rénovation
énergétique et d'autonomie énergétique
ces différents objectifs seront-ils tous
bien inclus au-delà de ce projet de loi
essentiel pour clarifier notre cap
énergétique pouvez-vous nous préciser le
contenu le calendrier des autres
documents programmatiques attendus en
matière d'énergie je peins bien sûr PPE
et à la stratégie nationale bas carbone
est déjà évoquée je pense aussi à la
révision de la stratégie sur l'hydrogène
ou la publication d'une stratégie sur le
carbone qui ont été annoncées voilà les
premières questions globales je vais
vous laisser répondre à ces premières
questions faire votre propos liminaire
puis mes collègues vous interrogeront et
en premier lieu monsieur le Président du
Groupe d'études énergie Daniel Gremillet
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente du
juste vous préciser que j'ai une
audition à l'Assemblée nationale sur les
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires à 18h et
donc je ferai mon possible pour faire en
sorte de respecter au top possible les
deux assemblées donc je pense qu'à 50
derniers Caraïbes il faudra que je vous
quitte et j'en suis absolument désolé je
m'attendais pas à ce que la séance de
questions au Gouvernement soit si longue
on aurait dû on l'anticiper c'est vrai
que c'est la dernière c'est pas la
dernière séance mais pour certains c'est
le cas et je veux les saluer ici je
ferai un mot d'excuse pour l'assemblée
donc madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs pour vous
répondre très rapidement quand la loi
cet automne quoi oui elle comprend les
six objectifs que vous avez mentionnés
quels sont les autres documents PPE et
CNBC en projet seront prêts également
pour cet automne la stratégie hydrogène
sera publiée dans les prochaines
semaines la stratégie sur le carbone a
été publié
afin du mois de juin je vais maintenant
peut-être plonger dans un propos plus
large madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs merci pour cette
audition de la sur la préparation de la
première loi de programmation énergique
climat vous savez vous l'avez dit cette
loi elle est issue de la loi énergie
climat de 2019 elle doit nous permettre
de fixer les grands objectifs de notre
politique énergétique au niveau
législatif avant qu'il ne soit détaillé
dans deux décrets la programmation que
réelle nouvelle de l'énergie et la
stratégie nationale bas carbone avec le
plan national d'adaptation au changement
climatique
de ces documents forment notre stratégie
énergie climat après de loi largement
votée par votre assemblée pour accélérer
les énergies renouvelables et nucléaires
nous disposons désormais des outils pour
avancer à la vitesse nécessaire je
précise d'ailleurs en termes de
calendrier qui les aurait été assez peu
logique de proposer une loi avant que
d'avoir finalisé la consultation et le
débat public qui nous a amené à
consulter les Français sur notre mix
énergétique ce qui a été fait du mois
d'octobre au mois de février dernier
avec un rendu des travaux au mois de
mars et par ailleurs que il était
également nécessaire de tenir compte des
textes du paquet climat dont je rappelle
qu'il fait 3500 pages donc il est assez
structurant au niveau européen paquet
climat dont nous sommes en train de
boucler les derniers textes en ce moment
et donc si nous voulons avoir une forme
de comment dire cohérence une paraissait
difficile et c'est bien au contraire le
choix de la logique et de l'ordre qui
après valu à ce calendrier nous avons
donc aujourd'hui nous disposons des
outils pour avancer à la vitesse
nécessaire il nous faut maintenant bâtir
un consensus politique dans le double
contexte des crises climatiques et
énergétiques sur notre stratégie énergie
climat l'enjeu de la transition est en
effet telle que nous devons construire
un consensus qui transcende les
étiquettes partisanes et le temps des
mandats politiques puisque il nous est
demandé de sortir des énergies fossiles
qui représentent deux tiers de notre
consommation énergétique des énergies
fossiles qui pèsent sur le portefeuille
des Français sur notre balance
commerciale sur la compétitivité de nos
entreprises c'est donc un impératif
absolu tant pour la protection des
consommateurs français que pour notre
souveraineté il s'agit plus profondément
de rebâtir l'intégralité ou la quasi
intégralité de notre système immunitaire
je le dis très simplement aujourd'hui
d'ici les années 2050
l'essentiel des capacités de production
qui fonctionnent aujourd'hui auront été
remplacés
pour construire cette loi j'ai proposé
une méthode qui repose sur trois piliers
la transparence tout d'abord sur les
travaux du gouvernement de
l'administration qui sont régulièrement
partagés la science et l'expertise
ensuite se sont elles qui doivent
alimenter nos travaux plutôt que
l'opinion l'émotion les considérations
électorales comme par le passé la
co-construction en fin c'est-à-dire le
dialogue entre tous les acteurs
concernés pour aboutir à un diagnostic
partagé ce travail d'écoute et de
partage nous l'avons d'abord mené auprès
des Français avec la concertation
citoyenne sur notre avenir énergétique
que j'ai lancé en octobre dernier une
concertation qui a permis de recueillir
plus de 31 000 contributions de tenir
des réunions physiques dans chaque
région et qui a réuni 200 jeunes de 18 à
35 ans tirés au sort sur tout le
territoire français y compris les
territoires ultramarins pour travailler
sur notre avenir énergétique pendant
quatre journées car les décisions que
nous prenons aujourd'hui se sont eux qui
en assumeront les conséquences de cette
concertation je retiens trois grands
enseignements d'abord contrairement à ce
qui a pu se produire par le passé le
débat ne s'est pas centré sur la seule
question du mix électrique il ne s'est
pas fait localiser sur pour ou contre le
nucléaire ou les éoliennes il s'est au
contraire centré sur la manière de
sortir des énergies fossiles deuxième
enseignement c'est la forte et nouvelle
adhésion la question de la sobriété
énergétique une sobriété qui est vue par
les Français comme allant bien au-delà
des changements d'habitudes individuel
et sur lequel ils appellent une
intervention forte de l'État et des
collectivités locales le troisième et
dernier enseignement c'est que les
Français sont en attente de plus
d'informations de sensibilisation de
formation aux enjeux de la transition
énergétique il est intéressant de voir
pour ceux qui assistaient au Conseil
national de la transition énergétique ce
matin que plusieurs prises de parole ont
repris ces demandes donc ça semble être
quelque chose d'assez central
les Français sont prêts à agir mais ils
veulent être accompagnés pour préparer
notre stratégie énergétique vous le
savez j'ai créé 7 groupes de travail qui
regroupent des parlementaires de la
majorité de l'opposition des
représentants d'associations des lieux
locaux des experts des représentants des
filières professionnels des associations
environnementales ou encore des
organisations syndicales six groupes
sont consacrés aux enjeux de clés de
notre stratégie en vocation être
reflétée dans les différents textes que
nous avons mentionnés la sobriété
l'efficacité énergétique la production
d'électricité la chaleur renouvelable et
les autres énergies des carbonées
l'innovation et quels sont ces
innovations qui peuvent peut-être
accélérer certaines des transitions les
zones non interconnectées le septième
groupe doit assurer le bouclage et la
synthèse car sinon l'exercice n'aurait
aucun sens je profite d'ailleurs de ce
propos pour remercier chacun ici d'avoir
accepté d'y prendre part tant je sais la
densité des travaux et de votre
investissement
ce que je souhaite avec cette méthode de
co-construction et de travail rigoureux
c'est que nous définissions ensemble une
bonne trajectoire énergétique alors
c'est quoi une bonne trajectoire
énergétique c'est d'abord une
trajectoire qui permet à la France de
respecter la trajectoire des accords de
Paris
c'est ensuite une trajectoire qui
utilise tous les leviers de
décarbonation à notre disposition sans
préjugés politique et idéologique nous
devons absolument respecter le principe
de neutralité technologique et j'assume
en particulier mais je pense pas que ce
soit un problème dans cette assemblée de
faire du nucléaire un des leviers pour
baisser nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'est aussi une trajectoire qui
boucle et qui permet d'équilibrer
l'offre et la demande de l'électricité
de chaleur et de biomasse cela va nous
amener à faire des choix j'y reviendrai
c'est enfin une trajectoire qui fixe un
cap pour permettre aux acteurs de
développer les emplois qui seront
nécessaires à la transition énergétique
ainsi que les capacités industrielles
nous parlons de plus de 500 000 besoins
de recrutement dans les 10 ans qui
viennent
construire cette bonne trajectoire c'est
un impératif pour l'indépendance et la
souveraineté de notre pays les premières
conclusions des groupes de travail qui
m'ont été remises le 4 juillet sont
explicites nous devons nous préparer un
mur INEX énergétique des 2030 un mur qui
fait peser un risque sur notre
souveraineté qui constitue l'un des
principaux enjeux régaliens des
prochaines années pour notre pays
concrètement il nous faut en moins de 10
ans
économiser je vais parler en terawater
vous pardonnerez mais en gros j'utilise
un réacteur 10 térawater un réacteur un
peu ancien vous me permettrait c'est pas
un EP R2 mais ça permet de fixer les
idées il nous faut économiser 350
térawatters soit l'équivalent de
l'énergie produite par 35 réacteurs en
un an et dans le même temps produire
presque la même chose en énergie
décarbonée à peu près la moitié en
électricité l'autre moitié en chaleur et
autres énergies renouvelables
quels sont par rapport à cela pardon
cela fait apparaître deux verrous dans
notre système énergétique le premier
verrou c'est la quantité d'électricité
produite avec un risque si nous ne
faisons pas suffisamment les économies
d'énergie que nous souhaitons d'avoir un
déséquilibre entre offre d'électricité
pardon c'est la quantité d'électricité
entre offre d'électricité et demande
d'électricité
notamment si nous ne rénovons pas
suffisamment vite les bâtiments le
deuxième verrou qui apparaît c'est un
verrou autour de la biomasse
c'est-à-dire que lorsque l'on empile les
besoins en biomasse de l'ensemble des
filières telles qu'elles les formules
aujourd'hui ce qui veut dire qu'il y a
un travail qui a été fait très en
profondeur pour les matérialiser on a
aussi une impasse entre les deux il va
falloir soit renoncer un peu d'un côté
soit produire plus de biomasse de
l'autre mais en tout cas il faut que ces
deux trajectoires se rencontrent et
c'est un des mérites de c'est vraiment
de poser ces problèmes il y a quatre
autres points de vigilance qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas des verrous je
les mentionne quand même parce que ça
pourrait le devenir dans le temps le
sujet des compétences je l'ai mentionné
le sujet des filières industriels toutes
les énergies n'ont pas la même empreinte
industrielle certaines ont une empreinte
faible en France d'autres une empreinte
très large je pense évidemment au
nucléaire ou au biogaz le sujet de la
pointe électrique qui aujourd'hui dans
les simulations de RTE ne fait pas
problème mais des simulations
complémentaires sont en cours avec
des hypothèses de de risques ou de de
non atteintes de certains objectifs pour
vérifier qu'on continue à passer et ça
vous l'aurez en septembre et puis la
compétitivité prix parce que il ne
suffit pas de produire beaucoup
d'électricité encore faut-il qu'elles
soient accessible en prix c'est un enjeu
essentiel pour le pouvoir d'achat des
Français c'est aussi un enjeu de
compétitivité de de nos entreprises et
toutes les énergies ne se valent pas
dans ce registre là
par rapport à cela quels sont les
leviers pour y répondre premier levier
la réduction de notre consommation
d'énergie qui passe donc vous l'avez
compris par la sobriété et par
l'efficacité énergétique sur la sobriété
le premier plan de sobriété que j'ai
présenté a permis d'économiser 12 %
d'électricité de gaz combinée sur
l'hiver alors c'est multi factoriel il
serait présente deux de dire que c'est
que le plan sobriété mais il y a
certainement contribué
pour poursuivre cette dynamique j'ai
présenté en juin dernier l'acte 2 de ce
plan afin d'en créer nos nouvelles
habitudes dans la durée d'aller plus
loin en matière de sobriété sur les
carburants et sur le numérique mais la
sobriété elle doit devenir structurelle
et au fond être au coeur de nos
politiques publiques en matière
d'aménagement du territoire il faut
passer d'un CAP ou nous changeons des
usages de manière rapide à un CAP ou
nous envisageons la sobriété comme un
élément pour penser les transports pour
penser l'habitation pour penser
l'organisation des activités économique
il faut en quelque sorte une
éco-conception de nos politiques
publiques il conviendra également de
valoriser l'effacement et la flexibilité
de la consommation c'est également un
enjeu majeur je sais que l'assemblée du
Sénat s'y intéresse particulièrement
puisque je viens de vous envoyer un
rapport sur ce sujet là je veux dire à
ce point que nous pouvons aller je pense
beaucoup plus loin que ce qui établi ce
rapport et que ce sera de mon point de
vue un des enjeux aussi sur lequel nous
pouvons approfondir des choses peut-être
pas forcément dans le cadre de la loi
mais dans le cadre
quoi qu'il y a certains sujets qui
peuvent passer par la loi
dans le cadre des travaux que de mon nom
sur la stratégie énergie climat j'ajoute
que nous nourrirons des travaux de lopex
qui viennent de mettre remis qui
explique aussi les quelques minutes de
décalage entre votre arrivée et mon
arrivée sur la sobriété ainsi que de
tous les travaux des sénateurs sur ces
sujets s'agissant de l'alimentation de
l'augmentation de la production
d'énergie des carbonées cela passe
d'abord par sur la défense inassable de
notre atout qui est le parc nucléaire
français c'est tout le sens de
l'Alliance Européenne du nucléaire que
j'ai fondé et qui regroupe aujourd'hui
14 États membres pour défendre cette
filière d'excellence au niveau européen
c'est tout le sens de la feuille de
route nucléaire que nous sommes en train
de décliner au niveau français qui va de
l'amant à l'aval du productible en
passant par l'extension de la vie de nos
centrales et le lancement d'un nouveau
programme cela passe aussi par la
poursuite du déploiement des énergies
renouvelables c'est un défi territorial
industriel et économique inédit afin d'y
répondre la loi d'accélération que vous
avez largement votée offre un levier
novateur avec la planification
territoriale et je veux le dire ici il
va falloir jouer sur toutes les énergies
renouvelables éolien terrestre et marin
solaire électrique et thermique
géothermie biogaz bois énergie et plus
globalement chaleur et froid
renouvelable sur ce sujet de la
production je rappelais qu'il y a trois
échéances temporelles qui sont
dimensionnantes
[Musique]
avant 2030 les décisions que nous
prenons aujourd'hui
produisent leur effet sur la chaleur
renouvelable le photovoltaïque et
l'éolien terrestre donc dans la chaleur
renouvelable vous avez la géothermie
et puis il faut compter sur
l'augmentation de la production de
nucléaires sur la base des actifs enfin
des réacteurs existants et c'est une
grosse partie de ce que nous allons
connecter au réseau dans les dans les
mois et les années qui viennent mais il
n'y a pas d'autres leviers ce serait
faux de le dire et il y a des décisions
sans regret sur la chaleur entre 2030 et
2050 les décisions que nous prendrons
elles vont permettre
sur l'éolien marin nouveau-nucléaire se
verront à ce moment-là sur notre réseau
et après 2050 il faudra remplacer nos
réacteurs enfin de vie et là c'est une
troisième équation qu'il faut d'emblée
anticiper puisque
61 gigawatts de nucléaire ça vaut pas 61
gigawatts de solaire je pense que vous
avez tous ces chiffres en tête il faut
grosso modo multiplier par 6
à peu près pour passer d'un giga V enfin
pour faire une équivalence entre solaire
et nucléaire
le troisième levier c'est celui de
l'innovation
hydrogène capture et séquestration
carbone nouvelle énergie qu'il s'agisse
de processus pyrogaséification les
hydroliennes marines la gestion de
l'énergie dans les bâtiments et les
transports je pense notamment aux
véhicules tout gris par exemple tous ces
éléments-là vont pouvoir contribuer à
faciliter notre transition énergétique
attention cependant à ce qu'elle se soit
pas perçu comme des martingales là où
certaines de ces énergies auront des
potentielles limitées ou des coûts très
élevés en tout état de cause la posture
dans laquelle nous nous mettons c'est de
financer l'innovation la R&D et
l'industrialisation de ces systèmes de
les suivre et d'être capable à tout
moment d'en valoriser le potentiel vous
avez pu constater sur les hydroliennes
marines que nous avons pris une décision
sur flovat très récemment avec la
perspective d'atteindre 70 euros du
mégawatt d'ici quelques années mais nous
ne sommes pas aujourd'hui à une capacité
industrielle permettant de le faire
la future programmation énergique climat
doit aussi être abordée sous l'angle de
la sécurité de l'approvisionnement
énergétique de notre pays et en
particulier dans le cas des zones
interconnectées il est inacceptable sur
notre territoire que des concitoyens
français n'est pas accès à des énergies
stables et accessibles en prix or
c'est une question qui se pose dans de
nombreux endroits en réalité alors pas
seulement à Saint-Barthélémy en ce
moment mais je pense que les territoires
ultramarins peut-être étaient surpris
l'émotion que susciter les délaissages
en France eux qui sont régulièrement
habitués et en termes d'exposition aux
énergies fossiles on a aussi des enjeux
qui sont majeurs sur ces territoires qui
peuvent devenir des territoires
d'expérimentation et pionniers en
matière de transition énergétique je
pense qu'il est important de regarder en
profondeur ces sujets là
pour réussir cette transition nous
devons relever le défi urgent des
compétences et des filières
industrielles je les dis sur le
programme du nucléaire c'est 100000
personnes et là on a vraiment le détail
des formations et des compétences qu'il
va que nous allons devoir recruter et
des premiers éléments qui remontent sur
les énergies renouvelables à rénovation
thermique et les réseaux on passe
facilement les caps des 500 000
personnes à recruter dans les 10 ans qui
viennent
il faut également
préparer nos filières et c'est nos
filières industrielles filières éolienne
photovoltaïques avec des états de
préparation et de compétitivité qui sont
très variables nous y travaillons avec
Roland Lescure sur les 10 filières clés
et le projet loi industrie verte était
l'occasion pour vous effectivement de
d'accompagner ce mouvement général au
delà des dispositifs de type pacte
solaire et pactéolien sur lequel nous
travaillons
le cap est donc clair nous devons
définir une trajectoire qui protège les
Français la souveraineté de notre pays
et qui nous permettent de franchir ce
mur énergétique mais vous voyez il
manque quelque chose c'est le
financement
en quelques petits mots permettez-moi
donc de vous dire qu'atteindre
l'objectif de neutralité implique un
effort d'investissement comme notre pays
n'en a pas connu depuis la révolution
industrielle au 19e siècle je dis ça
puisque les financements contribuant à
l'atteindre de nos objectifs climatiques
s'élever
en 2023 à environ 110 milliards d'euros
le travail mené par Jean pisanniféri
montre que pour sécuriser la trajectoire
des accords de Paris c'est entre 50 et
60 milliards d'euros additionnels par an
qu'il faut mobiliser ce niveau de
mobilisation de points de PIB dans une
économie on a repris en arrière
l'histoire économique de notre pays vous
leur retrouvez au moment du déploiement
des chemins de fer en France et au
Royaume-Uni c'est vous dire la
transformation que nous sommes en train
de mener je pense que cet exemple n'est
pas inutile aussi pour comprendre les
enjeux d'acceptabilité sociale et de
transformation qui qui sont devant nous
et les opportunités aussi qui sont
attachés
alors la mobilisation elle se fait
d'abord au niveau de l'État comme l'a
annoncé la première ministre dès le
prochain PLF l'état consacrera 7
milliards d'euros supplémentaires en
crédit de paiement et 10 milliards en
autorisation d'engagement pour les
transitions écologiques énergétiques la
deuxième réponse c'est de réussir à
mobiliser au mieux le secteur privé cela
suppose de fixer des trajectoires
claires et des cibles claires ce qui
sera l'objet de la programmation
que vous aurez appelée à voter cela
suppose aussi de réfléchir aux
instruments les plus efficaces le
rapport d'Yves Perrier remis ce matin
donne des pistes intéressante pour y
parvenir nous entrons tiendrons compte
dans le cadre des groupes de travail
préparatoires sur l'ail PEC sur le
financement j'en finirai en disant que
l'enjeu c'est avant tout d'accompagner
nos citoyens l'action publique doit se
concentrer sur les consommateurs pour
leur donner accès à l'énergie à un prix
représentant les coûts pour que personne
ne soit laissé au bord de la route pour
que personne ne doit renoncer à se
chauffer ou à se déplacer il ne saurait
y avoir de transition si elle n'est pas
juste et c'est pour cela qu'il nous
appartiendra collectivement de proposer
des solutions très concrètes de
véhicules de logement
de
d'autres ou d'autres éléments qui
permettent aux Français de choisir des
solutions qui soient compatibles avec la
transition énergétique d'où le leasing à
100 euros d'où les aménagements que nous
apporterons aux enjeux à ma prime rénov
et au certificat d'économie d'énergie
dans les prochaines semaines
merci beaucoup et je pourrais vous en
dire encore pendant deux heures donc
mais ne demandez pas parce que vu le
nombre de questions que j'ai en demande
on est bon pour deux heures je vais
passer la parole à différents
rapporteurs qui ont pendant ces trois
dernières années beaucoup œuvré sur le
domaine de l'énergie je vais commencer
bien sûr pardonner la parole à Daniel
grimillet président du groupe d'études
d'énergie et rapporteur entre autres du
projet de loi nouveau nucléaire Daniel
oui merci Madame présente chers
collègues madame le ministre je vous
remercie pour cette audition qui nous
permet de faire le point sur l'actualité
très dense du secteur d'énergie je
partage en tout point les propos de
notre présidente sur la nécessité de
soumettre rapidement au Parlement un
projet de loi quinquennal sur l'énergie
claire ambitieux exhaustif c'est une
exigence démocratique et urgence
économique pour notre pays
au-delà je souhaiterais vous interroger
sur plusieurs sujets le premier sujet et
l'évolution du mix énergie énergétique
électrique la mission transpartizane que
nous avons conduite avec mes collègues
Jean-Pierre Moga et Jean-Jacques Michaud
c'est prononcé sur un mix
majoritairement nucléaire à l'horizon
2050 partager vous ce point de vue nous
avons plaidé pour construire 14 EPR afin
de réaliser le scénario N0 de RTE mais
aussi pour évaluer la construction d'une
dizaine d'autres
EPR afin de tenir compte de son scénario
de réindustrialisation profonde chose
que nous espérons tous pour notre pays
qui nécessite aux environs de 750
terrawatters d'électricité en 2050
l'histoire nous a donné raison puisque
en juin dernier RTE a réévalué sa
prévision de consommation électrique
l'électricité elle pourrait être de 580
à 640 heures dès 2035 aussi quels sont
vos objectifs de consommation à
l'électricité de construction de
réacteurs par ailleurs ou en est
l'application de réglementaire et
administratif de la loi nouveau
nucléaire
que nous venons d'adopter si le Sénat a
obtenu la suppression de l'objectif de
réduction à 50% et du plafond à 63,2
gigawatts une révision simplifiée la PPE
et encore attendu pour y supprimer les
14 arrêts de réacteurs qui figurent
toujours je rappelle madame la ministre
que pour l'instant on a 14 qui pour
lesquels on n'a pas décidé
la décision qui a été prise c'est la
donc ça fait partie des points
importants quand ils procéderait vous à
cette décision en face si la réforme de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire et de
l'Institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire n'a pas pour espérer
dans la loi d'où on nucléaire le
gouvernement envisage-t-il de la
remettre sur le métier si oui par quel
vecteur et selon quel calendrier je
constate que l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation scientifique et
technologique le PEPS s'est positionné
sur le principe en faveur d'une réforme
pas plus tard qu'hier le deuxième sujet
est la protection des consommateurs dans
le secteur de l'électricité quel
dispositif susceptucturera au bouclier
tarifaire qui expire d'ici la fin de
l'année quelle sera la situation des
prix et des consommateurs et quel serait
le coût d'un nouveau dispositif la
présidente de la creux Emmanuel Bargon a
rappelé ici même la semaine dernière que
les charges de service public de énergie
liées à ce bouquet tarifaire serait de
30 milliards d'euros en pour 2023 dans
le secteur du gaz comment s'effectue la
sortie des tarifs réglementés de vente
du gaz les terres végé la le dispositif
de prix de référence prévue est-il
suffisant là encore quelle sera la
situation des prix et des consommateurs
selon la crue les terres végés sont
concernés 3 millions de clients
résidentiels soient 7,5% de la
consommation nationale de gaz en 2021 le
troisième sujet est la sécurité
d'approvisionnement si le groupe EDF
corrige peu à peu les difficultés dues
au phénomène de corrosion sous
contrainte la production d'énergie
nucléaires demeure historiquement faible
avec une production de
279 kw/h en 2022 contre 371 en 2021
aussi comment abordez-vous divers
prochains pour garantir la disponibilité
du parc électrique nucléaire comme
renouvelable lable mais aussi des stocks
et des imports de gaz
et faut-il s'attendre à des réductions
de consommation volontaires ou
obligatoires un peu dans le schéma que
nous étions pour l'hiver précédents le
dernier sujet à très haut négociations
européennes en cours notre commission
est celle des affaires européennes en
examiné quatre résolutions sur la
taxonie verte européenne le paquet
ajustement à l'objectif 55 la réforme du
marché électricité et l'industrie 0.net
si l'énergie est l'hydrogène nucléaire
sont aujourd'hui bien pris en compte
dans l'attaque son univers verte
européenne et les objectifs de thé
carbonation d'industrie c'est grâce à
vos négociations réelles mais au prix de
lourdes conditions de plus ils sont
encore largement
omis par le règlement industrie 0.net ce
cadre européen est-il suffisant pour
réussir en France la relance du
nucléaire autre point que pensez-vous
des grands contrats de long terme les
CFD et les PPA proposés par la réforme
du marché d'électricité envisagez-vous
de remplacer la reine par un cf après
[Musique]
2025 et enfin les interventions ciblées
dans la fixation des prix en cas de
crise sont-elles suffisantes
plaidez-vous pour en élargissement
pérenne des tarifs réglementés de vente
d'électricité aujourd'hui limitées au
ménage PME et collectivité d'un emploi
au-delà de 2 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires et 10 et TP voilà madame la
ministre les quelques questions que je
souhaitais vous poser voilà vous avez
vous avez 5 ans je vais demander aux
autres rapporteurs voilà de poser leurs
questions et d'essayer peut-être de
raccourcir un tout petit peu leur propos
Dominique Estrosi ça sonne donc
rapporteur de la mission d'information
sur les conditions d'utilisation de
l'arène qui sera bien gay co-rapporteur
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre effectivement je voudrais vous
interroger sur notre commission
d'information que nous avons rendu avec
Fabien gay sur les conditions
d'utilisation de la reine et sur les
possibles cas de fraude des conclusions
qui ont été côté ici dans cette
commission à l'unanimité mercredi
dernier alors la reine plus c'est à dire
le relèvement exceptionnel de la reine
de 19,5 terwattheure en mars 2022 et
critiqué certes la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie à estimer qu'il
a permis de limiter à 6 % la hausse du
prix de l'électricité pour les
consommateurs non éligibles au rve pour
autant le groupe EDF a déploré une perte
de recettes de 8,1 milliard d'euros et
plusieurs fournisseurs alternatifs ont
également déplorés une décision tardive
bien après la clôture du guichet et la
signature des contrats quel est votre
point de vue sur l'intérêt mais aussi
sur le coût de l'arène plus en outre la
reine plus a induit des comportements
pour le moins opportuniste de la part de
certains fournisseurs alternatifs ces
comportements peuvent consister en une
surestimation de leur demande d'arène ou
en l'absence de répercussion de cette
arène vers les consommateurs nous avons
eu connaissance de cas certes limitée
mais pour autant bien réel d'arbitrage
saisonnier certains fournisseurs ont
maximisé leur portefeuille de clients
sur la période d'avril à octobre afin de
bénéficier de la reine qui est calculée
sur cette période puis ce sont séparés
de ce portefeuille de clients en
augmentant fortement leur prix pour
revendre cette arène sur les marchés
alors la crue à estimer à 5,6% la
surévaluation de la demande d'arène pour
2022 elle appliquée une pénalité de 1,6
milliards d'euros au titre du fameux CP1
et de 21,9 milliards d'euros au titre du
second CP2 et par ailleurs actuellement
il y a quatre enquêtes qui sont en cours
avec trois saisies du corps 10 et des
sanctions quel est votre point de vue
sur ces surestimations et abus d'arrêt
et puis peut-être donc on a formulé 25
propositions législatives et
réglementaires je voudrais vous
interroger sur la première série de nos
propositions qui vise à corriger les
effets de bord de la méthodologie de la
reine nous préconisons de revoir ces
méthodes ces modalités de calcul en
revalorisation en revalorisant son prix
à 49,5 de euro du mégawattheure et en
laissant un changer son plafond légal de
120 terwatts il s'agit en somme
d'appliquer la loi pouvoir d'achat de
2022 qui prévoit que le gouvernement
saisisse la Commission européenne
donne-t-elle leur élèvement ceux qui
semblent-ils n'est pas encore le cas et
puis une deuxième série de propositions
qui tend à renforcer surtout les
contrôles et les sanctions qui sont
liées à la reine nous appelons à étendre
la notion d'abus d'arènes pour englober
tous les comportements opportunistes
dont les fameuses arbitrages saisonniers
nous proposons de surcroît de compléter
les sanctions du corps 10 pour lui
permettre de supprimer le bénéfice
d'arène en cas d'abus avérés nous
voulons enfin accélérer les procédures
devant le cordiste en instituant des
procédures de référé de signalement de
clémence mais aussi en élargissant sa
saisine notamment avec une capacité
d'auto saisine je pense que Fabien va
compléter mes propos monsieur gay co
rapporteur de cette belle mission
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
un an Dominique a dit beaucoup de
questions moi peut-être une madame la
ministre en août dernier je vous avais
interpellé sur des possibles abus et
frottes d'arène vous m'aviez répondu que
quand on était un sénateur sérieux il
fallait pas proposer des propager des
fake news bon finalement un an après on
y est les abus et les fraudes sont
nombreuses Dominique vient de le dire
un milliard 6 de CP1 c'est à dire une
amende alors qu'on nous a dit que on ne
pouvait pas revendre de la reine dès
qu'on a commencé nos auditions tout le
monde nous a dit qu'il a revendait un
milliard 6
et ça c'est une fin ça c'est un avis
tout à fait personnel et pas de la
mission je pense que c'est tout à fait
sous-estimé mais je n'ai pas le temps
ici le calcul est complexe mais de toute
façon je vais continuer à creuser cette
affaire parce que je pense qu'il y a
c'est largement sous-estimé d'ailleurs
on a posé la question à la présidente de
la crue qu'il n'y a pas répondu donc je
vais revenir sur le mode de calcul y
compris du CP1 mais moi je m'arrête
juste sur une question un védominique on
a été très surpris de la réponse où
aller le complément de prix 1
c'est-à-dire l'amende or nous a déjà
expliqué que ça n'avait jamais existé
parce que ça n'avait jamais été actionné
le cordis lui avant la semaine dernière
il s'était jamais il s'était jamais
réuni donc on nous avait vendu que tout
le système était bien cadré on voit que
ça a été un peu plus compliqué que ça et
puis quand on a posé la question à
l'ensemble des acteurs y compris votre
ministère ou aller le complément de prix
1 on a eu 45 personnes auditionnées je
vais pas dire 45 réponses Dominique ça
serait exagéré enfin on a eu beaucoup de
réponses à ces différentes un cours
consommateur un coup à EDF un cours aux
acteurs alternatif et puis au final ça
perçoit donc ça va être un peu commun
pour les acteurs alternatifs donc chacun
va pouvoir va devoir payer une amende
donc les 58 voir les 72 si on aime on
inclut les le complément de prix 2 et
puis chacun va devoir en payer et puis
peut-être qu'il va en recevoir aussi une
partie je vous avoue que avec Dominique
on est assez circonspect de dire comment
on fait on peut payer une amende d'un
côté puis en recevoir de l'autre donc on
ne vous a formulé une proposition moi je
pense qu'elle est assez sérieuse elle a
été votée à l'unanimité que lorsqu'il y
a un milliard 6 d'amende au minimum ça
revient au consommateurs et aux
consommatrices après il faut trouver la
forme parce que c'est au tarif
réglementé est-ce que c'est l'état le
cedf comment on revoit donc il y a une
mise en route de l'affaire évidemment
extrêmement sérieuse mais on peut pas
d'un côté tricher de l'autre payer
l'amende et après au final en recevoir
une partie dans la crise énergétique
telle qu'on est faut quand même que ça
revienne au consommatrices ou
consommateurs donc est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette proposition et
est-ce que c'est du règlementaire du
législatif mais en tout cas nous on est
prêt à y travailler pour résoudre cette
question voilà je vous remercie madame
la ministre merci je donne la parole à
Patrick Chauvet qui a été rapporté de la
proposition de loi aménagement du Rhône
mais aussi de celle accélération des
énergies renouvelables et on s'en
souvient merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais très rapidement faire remarquer
mes collègues ce que peut-être la
production d'énergie intermittente on
doit avoir un spot juste au dessus de
moi qui en est très très démonstration
c'était pour plaisanter évidemment
madame la ministre je souhaiterais vous
poser plusieurs questions sur les
hernies les derniers g les énergies
renouvelables tout d'abord si la loi
aménagement du Rhône de 2022 a réglé la
situation de la Compagnie nationale du
Rhône la CNR en prolongeant pour 20 ans
la durée de cette concession elle n'a
pas réglé le contentieux européen pesant
sur les concessions du groupe EDF
combien de concessions sont concernés
par ce contentieux et comment l'éteindre
la mise en place d'une quasi régie au
sein du groupe EDF où le rachat de
concessions par ce groupe évoqué par la
presse sont-elles des pistes à l'étude
d'autre part la loi accélération des
énergies renouvelables de 2023 attend
encore d'être appliqué
cette loi a modifié les critères de
sélection des projets d'énergie ou
d'hydrogène renouvelable soutenu par
rappel d'offres en consolidant leur
bilan carbone et en prévoyant une
contribution territoriale quand ces
nouveaux dispositifs seront-ils
opérationnels le gouvernement a-t-il
saisi la Commission européenne de ce
second dispositif qui nécessite une
notification Préalle cette loi aussi
introduit un cadre pour l'agrivoltaïs
afin de permettre l'essor en zone
agricole d'une production énergétique
respectueuse de celles alimentaires ou
en est l'élaboration des décrets et des
documents cadres départementaux et
comment les organisations
professionnelles agricoles sont-elles
associées à cette élaboration cette loi
a aussi prévu une accélération des
raccordements avec la modification de
l'ordre de priorité la mutualisation des
travaux de renforcement ou la révision
des schémas régionaux l'ordonnance
prévue sera-t-elle utilisée et quand les
décrets seront-ils pris au-delà de ces
textes je voudrais évoquer pour conclure
les charges de service public de
l'énergie afférente au projet d'énergie
renouvelable la présidente de la croix
nous a indiqué que les gains pour l'État
serait de 15 milliards et le chiffre est
variable au titre de 2023 comment ces
gains sont-ils ont-ils été utilisés je
vous remercie
de répondre à ces premières questions
sachant qu'il y a encore plein de
questions derrière je pense que l'on va
vous kidnapper fermer les portes d'ores
et déjà
mais vous pour certains d'entre vous
vous avez tout le loisir encore à
participer au groupe de travail énergies
climat monsieur
le rapporteur grillé
un porteur un jour un porteur toujours
sur le mix électrique quel est
l'objectif l'objectif c'est de réduire
la part du fossile dans notre mix
énergétique et donc de sortir de la
vision qui se limiterait à l'analyse du
mix électrique pourquoi parce que plus
on développe de la chaleur renouvelable
et du froid renouvelable dès lors qu'on
a la disponibilité de la biomasse ou que
l'on passe par la géothermie moins on
fait peser de pression sur notre système
électrique première élément deuxième
élément parce que sur la partie
part du nucléaire cela dépendra pas
seulement de notre souhait de poursuivre
l'exploitation des centrales nucléaires
et vous me demandez quand la décision
sera prise mais je vous dis qu'elle a
déjà été prononcé par le président de la
République puisqu'en tout état de cause
il a été très clair sur sa volonté de
prolonger les réacteurs
nucléaires si possible jusqu'à 60 ans et
que comme vous le savez EDF a remis un
premier étude qui matérialise que il ne
voit pas d'obstacles qui soient diriment
pour étudier pour la prolongation de ces
réacteurs nucléaires et que
l'autorisation l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire est en train de se pencher sur
le sujet puisque nous pouvons avoir dans
certaines situations la prise en compte
par exemple de phénomènes sismiques qui
nous amènerait à réviser ou être un peu
plus
[Musique]
précautionneux sur la capacité à
prolonger les réacteurs nucléaires mais
la décision politique elle-même telle
qu'elle est portée par l'exécutif elle
est prise et elle se s'illustrera dans
les propositions que nous ferons de loi
de programmation
sur la question de l'équilibre je pense
qui est aussi en sous-jacent entre
énergie renouvelable et énergie
nucléaire
je crois qu'il faut
sur le sur l'électrique distinguer les
énergies renouvelables qui se comportent
en stock c'est à dire l'hydraulique sur
lequel c'est une ce sont des décisions
sans regret d'investir massivement dans
ces énergies c'est les moins carbonées
c'est les plus pilotables vous avez une
deuxième catégorie d'énergie même si
elle fonctionne pas comme une énergie de
base vous avez une deuxième catégorie
d'énergie qui sont les énergies
électriques mais dont la disponibilité
est liée à des facteurs météorologiques
qui peuvent donc induire des variations
de production sur le réseau par rapport
à ça il faut à la fois aller vers les
énergies qui ont le taux de
disponibilité le plus important mais
éoliennes marines par exemple comparé
aux éoliennes terrestres et solaire
couplé des énergies qui ont des phases
différentes couplées du solaire et de
l'éolien permet de réduire le profil de
volatilité et troisièmement
effectivement prévoir des capacités de
stockage j'indique que nous commençons à
voir sur le territoire français des
déséquilibres offres de demandes c'est
le cas dans le Sud-Ouest sur lequel il
faut être attentif puisque c'est je
dirais des signaux faibles de ce que
nous aurons à gérer dans les années qui
viennent et que la Suède qui est très
avancée j'ai changé avec mon homologue
suédoise
hier nous indique elle qui est très
avancée dans la décarbonation de son mix
énergétique qu'elle a des situations de
vulnérabilité bien plus importantes
alors que son mix énergétique a été
renforcé aujourd'hui qu'il y a 10 ans
donc ces sujets là de la gestion du
réseau de la balance entre offre et
demande permanente de l'électricité de
la façon dont on tamponne des
productions de renouvelables qui ne sont
pas déclenchées à notre demande mais
déclencher sous des effets
météorologiques doivent être
immédiatement encodés pour qu'on le
transforme ça plutôt en force par
exemple produire de l'hydrogène bas
carbone à des moments le prix
l'électricité sera négatif plutôt qu'en
handicap qui est une difficulté
équilibrée l'offre et la demande mais ça
veut dire s'équiper en fonction d'où la
question de la flexibilité de notre
consommation d'énergie du stockage et du
pilotage des réseaux qui devient
beaucoup plus central dans la
problématique elle pète
la question
donc énergie et puis sur le nucléaire
dernier point
là aussi il faut mitiger les risques le
problème du nucléaire c'est les risques
génériques
c'est ce que nous venons venons de vivre
avec la corrosion sous contrainte si
l'on repère sur un réacteur
un problème quel qu'il soit il est donc
potentiellement répliquer dans tous les
autres réacteurs de la même génération
et donc on peut se retrouver dans une
situation où les X réacteurs concernés
doivent faire l'objet de maintenant voir
d'arrêt
d'où la nécessité de pas mettre les œufs
dans le même panier principe de bon sens
mais que nous vous proposerons
d'appliquer à notre mix énergétique
ce qui veut pas dire que et toutes les
énergies de notre point de vue seront
bonnes à prendre sur la question donc
les arrêts des réacteurs ça je vous ai
répondu sur la question IRSN ASN l'OPEX
vient de remettre son rapport donc on va
analyser ce rapport mais je vous
confirme notre intérêt effectivement
pour mener cette réforme de la Sûreté
Nucléaire cette réforme elle a pour
objectif principal de préparer notre
sûreté nucléaire
à la montagne qu'elle devra gravir pour
faire face à tous les dossiers qui vont
arriver les uns derrière les autres sur
sa table ce sur l'amour du
combustible puisque nous envisageons
d'étendre nos capacités de traitement
d'amour en amont du combustible ce de la
réparation et de la connexion des
centrales avec la corrosion sous
contrainte qui demande quand même
beaucoup de travail actuellement à la SN
et à l'irisn ceux de l'instruction des
nouveaux SMR et Amr qui va supposer de
s'organiser de manière autre ce lié au
réchauffement climatique et à son impact
sur les centrales nucléaires et sur la
sûreté nucléaire qui s'opposera de
renforcer les effectifs se lier à la
prolongation de nos centrales nucléaires
qui supposera d'anticiper un certain
nombre d'éléments de recherche et
développement et de valider les
schémas qui seront présentés par
l'opérateur et enfin se lier à la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs donc
vous vous voyez que la Somme et je ne
parle pas de la valve de combustible
avec pardon le retraitement les piscines
entreposage et la gestion des déchets
avec CGO donc clairement renforcement
des moyens renforcement des effectifs et
organisation la plus resserrée et la
plus solide possible pour faire face à
tout ces éléments sur la question
[Musique]
tac tac du bouclier du bouclier
tarifaire le bouclier tarifaire sur
l'électricité sera prolongée en 2024
pour les ménages et pour les très
petites entreprises et les très petites
collectivités locales l'amortisseur sera
également prolongé cela d'ailleurs déjà
été annoncé par la première ministre
s'agissant des tarifs réglementés du gaz
le prix de référence des tarifs
réglementés du gaz
des jeunes finalement comme avant le
tarif réglementé du gars je rappelle que
le tarif réglementé de gaz n'aide
réglementé que la formule de calcul qui
elle-même basée sur les prix de marché
et que cette formule était recalculée
tous les mois tous les mois donc en fait
c'est pas mécanisme de protection
c'était un mécanisme de prix de
référence et c'est ce que nous avons
répliqué avec la creux qui met en place
un mécanisme de prix de référence auquel
engie s'est engagé à se raccrocher pour
ces une partie de son offre tarifaire et
on constate aujourd'hui une bascule qui
se fait
sans difficulté de la part des derniers
c'est à peu près un quart des
utilisateurs du gaz qui étaient sous ce
contrat dit au tarif réglementé
sur tac tac tac l'énergie nucléaire 279
terawattheure en 2022 c'est un point bas
EDF a annoncé une trajectoire de
production qui s'établit entre 300 et
330 térawh et nous tablons dans les
analyses que nous avons de en
trajectoire de production nucléaire
c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est un
des éléments très important sur 360
térawattheure de production nucléaire en
2030 ça veut dire que c'est 80 terawatts
de plus juste pour mettre les chiffres
en perspective c'est
autant voir un poil plus que tout ce
qu'on fera en renouvelable électrique
c'est pour vous dire comme c'est
important
[Musique]
les importations sont sécurisées
j'insiste sur un point la sobriété n'est
pas une mode de 2022 2023 c'est vous
l'avez entendu dans mon propos
introductif un des leviers de
décarbonation de notre économie elle a
trois mérites elle ne coûte pas cher et
elle rapporte beaucoup aux consommateurs
et à l'état comme aux entreprises
puisque ce sont des dépenses évitées
elle a un deuxième mérite c'est qu'elle
a un effet sur le marché un effet pris
sur le marché le fait de dire qu'on est
capable de baisser notre consommation
d'énergie permet de baisser la pression
sur le coup de l'électricité sur les
marchés on l'a vu lorsque nous avons
passé le cap du 12 décembre le prix de
l'électricité s'est mis à baisser alors
qu'il avait atteint des sommets puisque
sur les marchés de gros je parle pas des
marchés évidemment des consommateurs
individuels sur les marchés de gros la
prime de risque était très élevé et les
acheteurs étaient prêts à acheter un
niveau très élevé l'électricité pour le
premier trimestre de l'année
et puis si vous voulez ne pas faire
marcher les énergies fossiles et bien
faut baisser notre consommation et
naître que sur les énergies qui sont bac
carbone et c'est ce que va permettre le
nouveau signal
Ecowatt puisque on vise rendre visible
quand est-ce qu'on rentre en zone de
consommation de production carbonée sur
les applications pour inciter les
Français qui sont soucieux leur
empreinte carbone d'effacer leur
production au moment des pointes
négociation en cours
donc vous avez raison de dire je vais le
dire très simplement il y a trois ans
prononcer le mot nucléaire au niveau de
la Commission européenne était quelque
chose de tabou
je crois que nous avons ces trois
dernières années
remis enfin nommer l'éléphant dans la
pièce et
réussit à montrer que le sujet n'était
pas un sujet d'un seul pays isolé dans
son coin mais un sujet majoritaire en
Europe puisque aujourd'hui la coalition
comporte plus de pays plus d'État
membres que il y en a hors de la
coalition sur l'alliance du nucléaire et
par ailleurs le Royaume-Uni les
États-Unis le Canada le Japon l'Inde la
Chine le Brésil porte des projets
nucléaires de différentes natures et
donc ce n'est pas une situation isolée
que de vouloir s'appuyer sur le
nucléaire pour faire je parle pas du
pays du Golfe que pour faire notre
décarbonation évidemment le nucléaire ne
s'oppose pas aux énergies renouvelables
et on va avoir besoin des deux on va
d'autant plus avoir besoin des deux
qu'on va avoir besoin d'énergie de base
donc ça tombe bien le nucléaire permet
de faire cela
il faut continuer il faut continuer
parce qu'on n'est pas arrivé
complètement au bout de la de l'exercice
l'hydrogène bas carbone et désormais
reconnu
et sur la taxonomie nous avons
effectivement obtenu des avancées
donc électricité market design les deux
les deux vecteurs donc le contrat long
terme pipi ou le système qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui pour les contrats d'énergie
renouvelables et qui viseraient en gros
à dire
j'achète sur une installation pour 20
ans de l'énergie à un prix donné et je
fais payer ce prix d'énergie derrière à
au consommateur et donc je j'enlève
toutes volatilité sur le prix payé par
le consommateur et je lui fais payer le
prix
de
de la des capacités de production et pas
un prix indexé sur un quelconque marché
étranger financier ou ou fossiles
c'est tout l'enjeu du CFD nous nous
pensons que les deux outils sont utiles
le pipier est un outil utile en
particulier pour des entreprises de
taille importante sophistiquées capables
de négocier avec un fournisseur
d'énergie qui peut valoriser aussi et
donc permet de tirer un prix très bas la
capacité de prise de risque la capacité
assez facile la capacité éventuellement
à coinvestir dans
l'investissement pour des acteurs un peu
moins sophistiqués soit il faut des
pipiers un peu standards ou la creux
mais son nez pour le dire très
simplement soit il faut des CFD qui est
effectivement un dispositif beaucoup
plus régulé mais ce n'est jamais que la
même démarche qui consiste à signer des
contrats à long terme et donner de la
visibilité sur le marché de façon à
réduire la volatilité des prix dans un
contexte où je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
dans mon propos plus l'électricité que
nous allons produire est intermittente
plus la volatilité des prix sera forte
sur le marché spot et on n'est pas tous
obligés d'acheter au marché spot ça peut
être un sujet de grande personne ou de
grands acteurs sophistiqués pour les
autres on leur assure des contrats qui
soient de 50 de 10 ans de 15 ans suivant
leur capacité à s'engager donc nous nous
pensons que les deux sont parfaitement
intéressant et que la reine
l'après à Rennes peut-être adressée par
ses différents instruments puisque la
reine c'est finalement une façon de
donner un prix stable et pas volatile
aux consommateurs après on peut se
battre sur le niveau de la reine et
constater qu'effectivement 42 euros qui
n'a pas évolué depuis 2012 c'est un peu
curieux dans un monde où nous
connaissons quand même des phases
d'inflation et où on peut penser que
lorsque le productible d'une entreprise
a diminué c'est coûts n'ont probablement
pas eux diminuer en conséquence et donc
le coût du mégawatt-heure a dû
probablement en production augmentée
donc c'est tout d'ailleurs le mouvement
que vous avez en demandant à ce que la
reine soit minima à 49,5 euros dans le
cadre d'une discussion avec la
Commission européenne je ne suis pas sûr
que la Commission européenne sera droit
à très court terme à cela mais nous
l'avons nous avons déjà présenté
quelques contacts de façon à ce que le
sujet soit pris en compte et nous
l'avions évidemment fait connaître la
loi mupa puisque elle nous permet de
montrer que ce n'est pas seulement un
sujet d'exécutif mais c'est un
préoccupation forte de nos parlements
sur la reine plus
oui c'est madame la sénatrice
sur la reine plus alors
on va être très clair la reine plus
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait elle a permis
de mettre 20 terawatt-heure de plus sur
le marché qui ont permis de baisser le
prix de l'électricité pour les
consommateurs ça c'est très clair et on
le voit dans les factures en particulier
des électro intensifs puisque leur accès
à l'arène est supérieur aux consommateur
lambda deuxième chose est-ce qu'il y a
eu surestimation de la demande il y a
deux phénomènes qu'on constate il y a
une surestimation de la demande sur
l'année 2022 dans un contexte de
sobriété effectivement les fournisseurs
en général pas plus EDF d'ailleurs que
d'autres n'avaient estimé la baisse de
consommation électrique ça on considère
que c'est pas un passager clandestin
c'est une un comportement du
consommateur qui n'avait plus anticiper
puis il y a une deuxième chose c'est une
surestimation grossière de la reine
première élément ou effectivement le jeu
de saisonnalités qu'on a pu constater
sur ces sujets là je rappelle que je
suis la ministre qui a demandé à
renforcer les
comment dire les capacités de sanction
et de d'enquête de la creux dans le
cadre du projet loi de finances
2023 et que j'ai par ailleurs mandaté la
creux pour faire ses enquêtes donc je
suis parfaitement à l'aise sur le fait
que il y a
ceux qui peuvent mal avoir anticipé leur
part de marché et dans un contexte où
l'électricité baisse de 8 à 9% ce qui ne
s'est jamais vu en 50 ans on peut
comprendre qu'il se soit qu'ils aient
pas été très juste et ça c'est le
premier niveau copain qui en fait pas
une sanction bien remboursement du trop
du tropieux on va dire en revanche
lorsqu'on est dans les passagers
clandestins il est parfaitement légitime
de sanctionner donc je suis à l'aise
avec le fait de durcir ses sanctions et
surtout c'est je pense la présidente de
la Creuse de radis la même chose ce sont
des enquêtes longue et donc il y a cette
difficulté à
cranter vite et à obtenir des des
bougies de la part des fournisseurs qui
ne respecteraient pas la loi ensuite à
qui va les ressources de cop1 et bien il
va au fournisseur alternatif qui ne sont
pas fautifs parce que c'est eux en
réalité qui se sont fait squeezies plus
que eux ont théoriquement eu plus de
clients et nous sommes en train de
regarder avec la DGEC si dans le cadre
particulier de l'année 2022 qui est
particulièrement spécifique avec cette
baisse de consommation d'électricité il
y aura pas effectivement justification à
ce qu'il y ait pas seulement les
fournisseurs alternatifs bons élèves
mais également EDF qui puisse bénéficier
de cela mais je vous rassure ça ne va
pas au fraudeur parce que sinon on
serait plutôt dans un mode Shadok et je
comprendrais que vous soyez fâché sur
les concessions hydrauliques de pistes
juridiques la quasi régie ou quasi régie
d'une part l'autorisation d'exploiter la
quasi régie à un inconvénient c'est
qu'elle sera probablement assortie de
remède demandant à EDF d'organiser son
entreprise et la gestion de son
entreprise avec des sortes de murailles
de Chine et donc en rigidifiant ces
processus de fonctionnement
il nous semble que c'est pas la
meilleure façon d'avoir cette
rigidification et donc nous regardons
les deux hypothèses
sont avec une analyse juridique qui est
assez pointue sachant que l'autorisation
d'exploiter paraît être une piste
intéressante à regarder sur les
notifications hydrogène que vous
mentionnez dans le cadre du projet de
loi accélération des énergies
renouvelables elles sont en cours au
niveau de la Commission européenne sur
la grille photovoltaïque le les
premières concertations étaient lancées
et la demande des acteurs du secteur
c'est de temporiser sur le décret parce
que il y a
beaucoup de
[Musique]
questions d'interrogations de peur
d'incertitude d'inquiétude liés à la
grivevoltaïsme et en particulier un
élément qui n'est pas énergétique mais
qui joue c'est la différenciation de
valorisation de l'hectare pour une terre
qui est accueille des panneaux
photovoltaïques quand bien même ça
serait combiné avec une activité
agricole et
le rendement à l'hectare pour un
agriculteur je donne un peu un chiffre
qui m'a été donné j'étais
sur Saône avec la Chambre d'Agriculture
locale et la FDSEA ils me disent 8000
euros de l'hectare sur de la
grivevoltaïsme forcément ça change un
peu les conditions
d'exploitation des agriculteurs alors la
bonne nouvelle c'est que c'est une façon
de agréable de mettre du beurre dans les
équilibres dans les épinards le problème
c'est que c'est un jeu à trois avec un
propriétaire foncier parfois donc ça
peut introduire des hiatus et le
deuxième problème c'est que ça rend
quasiment l'activité agricole comme
secondaire par rapport à l'activité
énergétique donc c'est cette équation là
qui va falloir
qui va falloir régler
sur tac tac tac les raccordements
l'ordonnance est terminée et elle alors
je sais pas si elle est déjà en
consultation si on va la mettre elle est
en consultation l'ordonnance
raccordement
il a et le décret sur la loi Littoral il
a été publié et en fait on a toute une
on peut en parler on a toute une série
de décrets qui s'établissent entre
maintenant enfin les premiers décrés
sont sortis fin je début juillet et les
nous essayons de sortir tout d'ici la
fin de l'année pour la loi accélération
des énergies renouvelables sur la loi
nucléaire pour monsieur le sénateur
grimillier le dossier d'autorisation de
construction a été déposée par EDF fin
juin donc nous avons tenu les délais et
c'est pour ça que c'était important que
la loi soit terminée promulguée début
juin
très bien Madame la Ministre accepte de
rester quelques instants de plus je vais
donc prendre les questions par non je
dois vraiment être deux je sais pas on
m'a dit 18h il y a 2 secondes
[Musique]
de prendre des questions de par deux
pour être sûr de vous libérer quand vous
devez partir et je m'en excuse auprès
des collègues astrings plus tard Anne
Catherine Loisier Franck montoget de
première question le plus rapide
possible oui merci beaucoup madame la
président de Madame Miss moi je voulais
juste revenir vous avez évoqué dans
votre intervention luminaire le sujet de
la biomasse sujet sur lequel j'avais
attiré votre attention il y a déjà un an
et demi où on connaissait déjà des
tensions
la biomasse étant d'abord utilisée pour
la chaleur première source de chaleur
renouvelable en France mais aussi pour
les matériaux les papeteries et se
trouve qu'aujourd'hui vous l'avez aussi
évoqué la biomasse et le solliciter de
plus en plus sur de nouvelles énergies
l'hydrogène les super con les
biocarburants et dans des volumes qui
sont explosifs
donc comment appréhendez-vous ces
arbitrages sachant qu'en fait ils sont
déjà présents sur le terrain à savoir
qu'il y a des volontés d'installation
notamment solvaient sur les
supercondensateurs qui demandent 150
millions de tonnes annuels sur des
durées très longues donc ça pose
vraiment une question sachant que nos
forêts effectivement aujourd'hui il y a
des dépérissement donc on tire beaucoup
de biomasse de nos forêts mais on peut
espérer que ça va pas durer
éternellement en tout cas ça ne durera
pas éternellement donc comment
souhaitez-vous procéder à ces arbitrages
moi j'attire votre attention sur les
cellules régionales biomass aujourd'hui
on se pose beaucoup de questions à
l'échelle régionale donc comment est-ce
qu'on peut leur donner un rôle
d'arbitrage puis juste revenir sur
Lausanne et les EnR puisque dans la
pépelzanne enfin dans la loizanne les
EnR ne sont donc pas sortis du compte
foncier sauf agrivoltaïs donc comment
pensez-vous atteindre les objets il le
serait dans dans votre proposition dans
le PV au sol le PV au sol est pas compté
pivot au sol la grivevoltaïsme et les
éoliennes ont des emprises très petites
alors d'accord alors j'avais pas noté ça
du tout dans la loizane c'est un
apparaissait pas donc dans la loi c'est
et Franck
de petits sujets on commence à entendre
dire que finalement on pourrait se
passer de la loi de programmation
énergétique climat
si d'aventure par exemple je ne le
souhaite pas elle n'était pas voter par
le par le Parlement et qu'on pourrait
que vous pourriez que le gouvernement
pourrait prendre par des craies
donc des mesures concernant la PPE et la
SNBC dans votre propos d'ailleurs à
propos de la CNBC vous avez laissé
entendre qu'elle était voilà qu'elle
était qu'elle était adoptée quelque part
ça m'a un peu étonné moi j'ai compris
que on attendait la version 3
voilà donc je voudrais savoir par
rapport à la loi de programmation quelle
est votre votre position parce que c'est
pas quand même un petit sujet vous avez
évoqué la mobilisation du secteur privé
moi je je vois mal comment effectivement
on pourrait se priver de la loi de
programmation pour notamment accompagner
les efforts du secteur privé par rapport
aux investissements en gros moi j'essaie
de me retrouver dans les tombeaux de
chiffres là qui nous tombe sur la sur la
figure de partout sur un sujet qui est
extrêmement compliqué ça je j'ai essayé
de me pencher sur les travaux de la du
secrétaire général à la planification
écologique ils ont beaucoup faut bosser
c'est impressionnant mais après bon il
faut faire pas toujours facile à
comprendre c'est 500 milliards en fait
d'ici 2030 cette fois cette quarante
neuf en gros 65 70 milliards par an
c'est on est à 500 milliards
ce que nous annonce Jean pisenifferi et
Madame Mahfoud c'est qu'il y en a la
moitié correspondant de ces 500
milliards font publics et que dans la
moitié des fonds publics ces
collectivités locales et et le reste le
reste pour l'État c'est ce que j'ai
compris moi des chiffres ou me
corrigerez si c'est pas si c'est pas ça
qu'il fallait comprendre comment dans la
situation où elle se trouve
finance ton tout ça
moi je j'aimerais que si vous le pouvez
que vous nous disiez notamment sur le
nucléaire combien va coûter à l'état de
nucléaire nouveau le grand carénage etc
ça va être une proportion me semble-t-il
importante de la part qui revient à
l'état c'est tout ça c'est autant de
graines de graines de questions qui se
posent et qui vont conditionner la
réussite la réussite du plan et la
question des recettes va se poser à
travers la fiscalité etc je pense qu'en
restant dans la situation actuelle avec
une fiscalité carbone qui est amenée
fossil à diminuer il va falloir trouver
les ressources ailleurs et où les
trouve-t-on merci Madame
et répondez à ces deux premières
alors sur la biomasse plusieurs choses
d'abord les premières
mouture de donc on parle bien monsieur
le sénateur Monger la stratégie
nationale à carbone numéro 3 c'est sur
ça que nous travaillons depuis
maintenant
15 mois 16 mois non non j'ai bien parlé
de ça je n'ai donc nous sommes que nous
sommes en train de faire atterrir pour
être un état de mise en concertation de
façon à ce que on est l'ensemble des
textes elle pètent SNBC et PPE en même
temps comme ça c'est un combo des choses
de niveau réglementaire mais ça permet
d'éclairer le propos pour le législateur
que que vous êtes
sur donc la la stratégie nationale bac
carbone le premier run qu'on avait fait
nous donner effectivement quasiment une
consommation x 3 de la biomasse
disponible donc là il y avait un gros
problème et on a travaillé à préciser
les trajectoires à la fois de demande et
de l'autre côté d'offres sur les
trajectoires de demande la première clé
et la part de ce que nous importerons
par exemple les biocarburants rien dit
que nous allons demain
fabriquer en France 100% nos
biocarburants je le dis d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui nous fabriquons 0 de
notre pétrole
raffino un tout petit peu mais
l'approvisionnement était
essentiellement réalisée à l'extérieur
donc il faut avoir en tête que
probablement nous aurons une partie qui
sera
importée depuis l'extérieur notre
objectif est de réduire notre dépendance
et donc d'avoir quelque chose
d'équilibré on n'a pas et ça sera je
pense un vrai débat à
Calais sur ce que c'est 30 70 20 80
deuxième élément c'est les vecteurs de
production de plus de biomasse vous en
avez plusieurs vous avez évidemment
l'installation de et ça c'est une
politique et qui suppose
informations et je pense une
contractualisation avec les agriculteurs
je laisserais
Mark fino le cas échéant complété parce
que il a vraiment travaillé ces sujets
là avec des agriculteurs donc les haies
les cultures intermédiaires à valeur
énergétique
la gestion de la forêt dont je rappelle
que cette gestion de la forêt elle est
désormais
sous l'égide de la directive
renouvelable qui prévoit que il y a un
système de cascadille donc on fait pas
n'importe quoi dans la gestion de la
forêt et on peut pas mettre utiliser la
forêt pour nourrir
le bois une filière bois énergie si on
ne respecte pas le gros œuvre enfin
voilà des utilisations différentes et
donc l'essentiel de notre bois énergie
demain ça doit être des coproduits de de
l'utilisation des prélèvements qui sont
faits sur la forêt et notre
positionnement aujourd'hui et de
considérer qu'il y a trois usages
prioritaires et que c'est pas négociable
qui sont l'alimentation humaine par
rapport à la biomasse l'alimentation des
animaux et le pic carbone et que le
l'énergie arrive en quatrième position
dans l'utilisation de la biomasse je
pense que c'est important si on veut pas
décaler enfin résoudre un problème pour
en ouvrir un nouveau en particulier sur
la partie souveraineté alimentaire donc
et donc par rapport à ça il y a des
choix à faire et probablement des
des équations à revoir à la baisse nous
nous considérons que c'est dans un des
enjeux sur le bioga c'est à dire le
biogaz ne pourra pas remplacer un pour
un le gaz naturel ont même en poussant
les feux très fort on arrive à
50 terawattheure de biogaz en 2030 c'est
10% de ce que nous commençons
aujourd'hui de gaz naturel
voilà et sur la forêt le grand jeu c'est
d'avoir une gestion durable de la forêt
et la grande difficulté c'est pas
tellement de toucher les grands
propriétaires qui ont ce type de gestion
durable mais la multiplicité de petits
propriétaires pour lequel le plan simple
de gestion durable de la forêt fait 100
pages
[Musique]
et donc voilà donc j'ai pas besoin de
vous expliquer la difficulté donc c'est
vraiment le sujet sur lesquels il faut
trouver un levier un intérêt à agir pour
pour passer ce cap là donc c'est ce que
ce sur quoi nous travaillons
il s'agissant s'agissant du prix je
rappelle une chose on a une ressource
qui n'est pas du tout par exemple prise
en compte aujourd'hui 7% du chauffage
bois énergie est fait sous forme de
chauffage enfin
ouvert ou de chaudière qui sont pas
performantes vous avez des gains de 1 à
7 par rapport à du bois énergétique Pelé
très performant
au passage vous réduisez aussi
massivement les émissions de particules
fines donc en fait il y a un peu on
retrouve un peu cette même logique de
prime à la casse à mettre en place sur
tout des systèmes qui sont
inadaptés au réchauffement climatique et
qui vont permettre de nous donner de
l'aisance sur la biomasse et de l'autre
côté de résoudre un problème puisque
aujourd'hui le bois énergie c'est plus
de 60%
et du polluants à particules fines ce
qui est gigantesque
tac tac sur
donc PPE et je pense que j'ai répondu à
votre question
la mobilité alors je le redis il y aura
un projet de PPE un projet de SNBC 3 qui
accompagnera le projet de lpk à
l'automne plus précise
alors et après vous dites qu'est-ce qui
se passe si vous votez pas je vous
rappelle que vous avez vous-même
vous-même sénateur
mais si vous comprenez Si vous
non non moi je vous dis ce qui est très
clairement il y a la première ministre a
dit donc je pense qu'on peut lui faire
confiance peut-être plus que les médias
sur ce qu'elle souhaite faire dans les
mois qui viennent quand même
il y a une PPE une des projets de PPE de
SNBC et de lpk qui constituait un
ensemble qui seront présentés à
l'automne et je précise quand même une
chose c'est que vous avez vous-même voté
une demande de mise à jour de la PPE
dans les 12 mois donc
ce n'est pas nous qui demandons à
ajuster ça c'est vous qui nous l'avez
demandé je me permet de le rappeler
la traduction d'une des traductions et
c'est pour ça que je vous redis c'est
pour ça que je vous redis que afin que
tous vous ayez la vision complète des
propositions de textes que nous faisons
nous avons un projet de PPE un projet de
SNC et un projet de lpk qui sera
présenté à l'automne la helpk elle fait
l'objet d'un circuit législatif et la
PPE et la SNBC sont dit décrets qui
arrivent ensuite mais vous avez en fait
la plus grande transparence avec les
trois textes qui arrivent ensemble parce
que ils ne sont pas de même niveau ils
disent pas exactement la même chose
puisqu'ils sont en poupée russe voilà et
vous m'avez par ailleurs demandé
d'actualiser de toute manière la PPE
dans les 12 mois qui viennent et ça
c'est pas moi qui l'ai fait c'est vous
allez allez
il y avait une dernière question sur le
financement mais je pense que là on va
devoir
sur les financements vous avez quand
même un certain nombre d'abord
je suis pas sûr que la taxe carbone va
diminuer enfin je vois pas à quel titre
elle diminuerait dans les mois qui
diminuer
où est mon fréquence ça fait deux tiers
de votre mix énergétique et que elle
augmente en taxation
disons que d'ici 2030
oui
d'ici 2030 le sujet
je pense que le sujet est plus mordant
en fait sur les zones d'un
interconnectées ou pour le coup le froid
de mer qui est fondé sur les
importations d'énergie fossile risque de
je peux me tromper mais c'est pour ça
qu'on fait cette mission risque de
mordre plus rapidement au moment où on
voudra des carboner parce que là pour le
coup c'est direct et c'est dans le
budget
bien je vous propose mes chers collègues
de poser toutes vos questions
je vous propose de poser toutes vos
questions je propose d'ailleurs à Franck
montoget que la prochaine commission au
mois d'octobre au mois de novembre quand
on sera en plein je pense dans ces
programmations pluriel repose cette
question du financement qui à mon avis
mérite plus que 5 minutes parce que ça
va être compliqué donc je pose je vous
demande de poser les questions si on a
le temps parce qu'on a encore un petit
quart d'heure
on vient de gagner un quart d'heure si
on a le temps Madame la Ministre répond
sinon je vous demanderai peut-être de
répondre par écrit si c'est possible
amalgaquer Michelin
madame la ministre un sujet ciblé mais
qui fait couler pas mal d'encre il
existe plusieurs chemins en fait pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone à 2050
le scénario du secrétariat général à la
planification écologique qui s'appuie
sur un effort particulièrement important
du secteur du bâtiment notamment par une
mesure fort discutée l'interdiction des
chaudières à gaz dès 2026 dans le parc
immobilier existe il existe un autre
scénario celui de des terrains de
territoires issus des perspectives gaz
2022 qui préconisent de réduire les
consommations et de verdir le gaz plutôt
qu'interdire l'équipement plus
globalement à une propose une
mobilisation plus équilibrée des
énergies renouvelables et dans
différents secteurs un scénario qui
permettrait d'atteindre les mêmes
objectifs de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre à 2030 et à 2050 deux stratégies
de voix mais aux conséquences bien
différentes la mesure d'interdiction des
chaudières impacterait 12 millions de
ménages 40% des foyers dans un contexte
économique déjà bien fragile cette
interdiction
constituerait encore une charge
supplémentaire dont se passerait bien
les ménages et les collectivités
territoriales et enfin cette mesure va
également se traduire par un transfert
massif vers le chauffage électrique et
donc une explosion de la demande
d'électricité qui est d'ores et déjà qui
est déjà bien problématique aujourd'hui
quel est votre position sur ces deux
scénarios envisagez-vous d'assouplir
d'ores et déjà ou de reporter l'entrée
en vigueur de cette disposition et quel
accompagnement financier des Français et
des collectivités territoriales
prévoyez-vous je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues lundi
dernier un incendie à la centrale de DF
de Saint-Barthélemy à privé l'île de 60%
de sa capacité de production électrique
c'est incident n'est pas une grande
surprise compte tenu de la vétusté de la
centrale l'utilisation de groupe
électrogène dans la grande majorité des
foyers des hôtels se sont équipés depuis
le passage de l'ouragan Irma Paly
l'absence d'électricité Mew prix d'une
aberration écologique et d'une pénurie
de carburant dans l'île la situation
s'est vite rétablie avec l'intervention
de DF Guadeloupe mais si la production
devrait rester quelques temps en deçà de
20% des capacités sachant qu'à pleine
capacité elle satisfait à peine les
besoins de l'île
depuis 2014 la collectivité de
Saint-Barthélémy discute avec EDF pour
remplacer les moteurs qui sont vraiment
vétustes ont des moteurs nouvelles
génération fonctionnant au biocarburant
nous ne savons pas à quel stade on est
le processus ni ne disposons de
calendrier la collectivité importante
satisfaite toutes les exigences requises
par EDF et la creux premièrement on
adaptation notre fiscalité locale après
la réforme de 2005 et la collectivité
s'est engagée au prélèvement de la CSPE
auprès de ses administrés elle
subventionne aussi l'installation de
panneaux photovoltaïques elle vient
d'accueillir pour 6 millions d'euros une
turbine destinée à produire de
l'électricité à partir de l'incinération
des déchets en outre votre cabinet me
confirme que vous avez bien reçu la PPA
de Saint-Barthélémy mais nous ne savons
pas si elle était approuvée donc nous la
question sera mais question seront les
suivantes pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît
m'indiquer des échéances pour le
renouvellement de ces moteurs et la
fixation du prix de rachat de l'énergie
solaire merci beaucoup Micheline Henry
Cabanel et ensuite Christian dont ça va
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre le développement des panneaux
photovoltaïques chez les particuliers
tenant un jeu me semble-t-il important
pour développement du solaire l'agence
l'Environnement et de la Maîtrise de
l'Énergie estime une surface toiture
inexploitée de plus de 300 GW malgré les
multiples mesures incitatives pour les
particuliers à développer chez soi
l'énergie solaire comment peut-on
réussir à combler ces surfaces
inexploitées
relatifs à l'article 54
pour protéger les terres agricoles donc
les les trois ministères ensemble-t-il
de présenter des projets de décret donc
aux organisations agricoles qui
soulèvent d'ores et déjà intolé
on craint
un petit peu quand même elle semble
crâne que ce décret ne fasse tomber les
rares mesures d'encadrement que nous
avions obtenu lors de l'examen du texte
au Parlement est-ce que vous pouvez nous
apporter des précisions sur ce sujet
madame madame la scénatrice guacière il
y a aucun scénario et c'est écrit nulle
part
chaudière se pose pas là comme ça
brutalement de but en blanc
sans
effectivement le prendre en compte donc
qu'est-ce qui est à l'oeuvre aujourd'hui
il s'agit d'adresser pour le fioul et
pour le gaz un accompagnement des
différents types de bâtiments bâtiments
publics tertiaires
bâtiment
privé tertiaire logement individuel et
logement collectif pour savoir comment
on réduit l'empreinte carbone de ces
différents bâtiments vous avez deux
manières de le faire la première manière
consiste à baisser la consommation
d'énergie et ça c'est tout l'enjeu de la
rénovation thermique et je rappelle que
c'est pas rien ça peut être sur des
bâtiments qui ont été construits au
moment où la question de la sobriété
énergétique était moins pragnante ça
peut être 30 à 50% voire plus de gains
énergétiques donc sans changement même
de chaudière et les recommandations qui
sont faites c'est dernier ces travaux
par une chaudière qui soit performante
et adaptée aux travaux de rénovation
thermique et de pas commencer par le
changement de la chaudière puisque sinon
on va la surdimensionner et c'est pas
très gagnant pour le ménage et c'est
retardé le moment où on traite la
question et c'est dans ces conditions-là
qu'on risque de peser sur le mix
électrique donc ce que nous faisons
enfin ce que nous sommes en train de
pousser c'est d'avoir un meilleur
accompagnement des ménages pour les
mener sur les travaux soit de rénovation
globale on veut doubler le nombre de
rénovations globales et là effectivement
on traite à la fois l'isolation et la
chaudière dans des travaux profonds soit
des bouquets de travaux mais beaucoup
plus efficaces ou on traite les
principaux problèmes d'isolation et on
l'a sorti d'un changement de chaudière
avec des chaudières qui sont pas
nécessairement électriques c'est le
dernier point je disais que le bois
énergie c'est à peu près 20-25%
de du chauffage en France vous avez
également la géothermie alors certes il
y a une petite pompe électrique il faut
bien le dire mais qui en termes de
consommation électrique est beaucoup
plus faible vous pouvez avoir du
couplage pompe à chaleur et
[Musique]
un complément par exemple Pelé qui est
une bonne solution lorsque vous êtes
dans la ruralité avec des pointes de
froid donc vous passez 90% de la saison
avec votre pompe à chaleur et quand ça
devient très froid le complément est
fait avec le Pelé c'est plus efficace et
puis évidemment dans les logements
collectifs la chaleur renouvelable les
réseaux de chaleur nous les poserons
fortement et comme vous avez pu le
constater on a aujourd'hui des élus
locaux qui adhèrent avec à cette vision
puisqu'on a plus de 900 millions d'euros
de projets déposés au fond indem alors
ça coûte pas si cher que ça puisque
c'est un coût d'abattement de la tonne
carbone qui est du côté de 70 80 euros
donc ça fait partie des bons retours sur
investissement entre guillemets et avec
aussi des bons niveaux de prix en termes
de chauffage pour pour les habitants
donc ce sont des solutions qui nous
paraissent sans regret
vous avez totalement raison mais c'est
pour ça qu'il y a un front chaleur et
c'est pour ça que nous sommes en train
de le renforcer donc pour et donc tout
l'enjeu de cette consultation sur la
décarbonation de des bâtiments c'est
justement de donner de la visibilité et
de regarder à la fois sur le volet de
l'accompagnement des différents acteurs
faut pas oublier le secteur tertiaire et
faut pas oublier le secteur public et
également sur les solutions puisque
au-delà des différentes solutions de la
manière dont on peut bouger les
certificats d'économie d'énergie ou les
les subventions de ma prime rénov ou la
TVA sur les chaudières enfin tous ces
éléments de de signalerie c'est
également
la façon dont on dont on crée les
filières industrielles aujourd'hui la
France a des acteurs sur les pompes à
chaleur qui sont en train d'accélérer je
pense notamment Atlantique qui a annoncé
une extension de son usine à Billy berc
la sénatrice connaît bien ce lieu avec
un passage de 150 000 pompes à chaleur à
300 plus de 300 000 pompes à chaleur en
2027 et qui regarde l'installation d'un
deuxième site qui était initialement
prévu en Pologne et qui pourrait à la
faveur des mesures d'industrie verte
être installés en France donc c'est très
concret et c'est ces trois volets là que
nous devons accompagner les grands les
grandes solutions l'accompagnement et
les filières industriels
sur
Saint-Barthélemy alors question très
spécifique je dis pas que je répondrai
parfaitement à ce que vous m'indiquez
d'abord dire évidemment je pense que
c'est un exemple assez patant de
vulnérabilité des zones interconnectées
françaises et qui doivent appeler le
même intérêt la même le même niveau de
préoccupation que pour la métropole nous
sommes quand même beaucoup plus
résilient
donc là c'est un incendie qui s'est
déclaré dans un local de distribution
qui a entraîné une rupture
d'alimentation de près d'une heure sur
toute l'île suivi d'une période de
délestage
et
EDF à peu près rétabli la situation mais
il y a encore des efforts de sobriété
assez appuyées qui sont réalisées pour
permettre pour éviter le délestage en ce
moment et des renforts devraient
également arriver aujourd'hui et demain
pour connecter d'autres groupes secours
s'agissant de la PPE de Saint-Barthélémy
donc elle a été reçue fin mars j'ai
sollicité plusieurs instances pour bien
en comprendre les enjeux du
dimensionnement de la centrale de
Gustavia mais aussi pour répondre à la
question de l'évolution du tarif de
rachat du photovoltaïque la CRU a été
saisie le 7 juillet dernier sur ces
trois aspects donc le dimensionnement la
centrale les niveaux de prix de rachat
d'électricité photovoltaïque qui aurait
vocation à constituer le référentiel
d'un arrêté tarifaire que pourrait
prendre la collectivité et l'impact de
la PPE sur les charges de service public
de l'électricité ces demandes devraient
permettre de formuler une réponse
circonstancielle à collectivité d'ici
octobre 2023 et de travailler avec elle
ensuite l'aspect réglementaire
c'est-à-dire le décret PPE et l'arrêter
tarifaire local
sur
le PV chez les particuliers
comment on a accès à la surface
inexploitée peut-être rappeler que le PV
sur toiture sur petit toiture n'est pas
la
c'est pas la en termes de rapport
qualité-prix c'est un des éléments où on
peut avoir des prix de l'ordre de 200
250 euros du mégawattheure je parle le
prix de l'électricité c'est à dire avant
d'empiler le reste
alors ça je chacun sera libre de son
appréciation
chacun sera libre de son appréciation il
paraît qu'il y a des briques solaires
des choses très très jolies mais un peu
plus coûteux
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a aussi
cette ce sera là pour pour les
particuliers nous ce qu'on essaye de
faire c'est de
développer ou de faciliter le
développement de l'autoconsommation
collective pour permettre dans des
boucles et notamment sous l'égide des
collectivités locales mieux
d'avoir de mobiliser les meilleurs
toitures
pour avoir un prix plus compétitif et
pour permettre de servir plusieurs
usages des usages de services publics et
des habitants il y a également la
question du solaire thermique et pas
inintéressant ne serait-ce que pour
adresser les pointes là aussi on a des
coûts qui sont pas toujours
compétitifs donc c'est ce ces points
d'équilibre il faut que nos technologies
on a tellement à faire sur les énergies
renouvelables que la proposition que
nous faisons c'est déjà de pousser
énormément les feux sur ce qui est le
plus compétitif pour les habitants en
termes de coûts de l'électricité au coût
du mégawater de chaleur avant que de
passer à des sujets plus compliqués même
si il y a un intérêt à mobiliser les
surfaces artificialisées parce que pour
le coup ça c'est immédiatement
disponible et même si le PV ne compte
pas dans le zan ça prend quand même de
l'espace que vous pourrez pas utiliser
autre chose donc moi j'ai déjà
effectivement des élus locaux qui me
disent bah vous comprenez bien que quand
bien même ça compte pas j'ai un plutôt
envie de réserver cet espace là à un
bâtiment industriel et si je dois faire
du PV je ferai sur le toit du bâtiment
industriel ce qui me paraît pas infondé
sur la question du décret de l'article
54 c'est ce que je vous ai indiqué c'est
à dire les consultations démarrer avec
effectivement
des rédactions qui circulent mais il y a
indiqué il y a une demande de
temporisation qui est assez claire
parce que le sujet
suscite soit un très grand engouement
sur la thématique vous n'allez pas assez
vite soit une très grande réticence sur
la thématique l'erreur de questions
qu'on développe du la grivevoltaïsme sur
mon territoire et que ce grand écart est
observé
dans un certain nombre de chambres
d'agriculture c'est à dire que les
acteurs ne sont pas alignés et que donc
les je vois le patron des chambres
d'agriculture la semaine prochaine et je
vais probablement déplacer on avait avec
Marino organisé webinar sur le la
grivevoltaïsme il nous est de temporiser
un peu pour permettre de
resserrer déjà dans lever les
tous les
c'est même pas une question d'irritante
c'est déjà qu'on ait la même
compréhension de ce dont on parle avant
que de rentrer dans je suis d'accord je
suis pas d'accord mais déjà d'éliminer
les zones de malentendus pour pouvoir
savoir sur quoi on peut s'entendre et
est-ce qu'effectivement il y a
différentes questions nous notre vision
de la révoltaïsme c'est la définition de
la dame c'est-à-dire que elle doit
nécessairement être complémentaire d'une
activité agricole avoir
une utilité agronomique ou de bien-être
animal ou
assurantielle ou il y a un quatrième
élément qui m'échappe il faut remplir au
moins deux bénéfices pour pouvoir cocher
la case agrivoltaïs ce que nous avons
fait à date c'est un guide pour aider
les élus à faire leur planification
énergétique qui devrait dû se viser la
semaine prochaine moi j'ai écrit à tous
les tous les mers
et tous les présidents
d'intercommunalité alors rappelant la
question la planification énergétique
dans leur donnant aussi des outils
cartographies sur le portail de
l'hygiène qui permet de faire des
filtres sur des enjeux de biodiversité
le cadastres solaires le potentiel
éolien etc pour définir leur zone la
liste et les noms des
référents préfectoraux en préfecture
enfin voilà on met tout sur la table
pour les accompagner dans leur
planification énergétique et on va faire
pareil avec les Chambres d'agriculture
[Musique]
beaucoup voilà je vous le dis parce que
c'est un petit warning que je fais je
j'en suis tellement consciente que ce
petit courrier que nous nous renvoyons
c'est une série de d'appui et d'aide et
je donne même le numéro de téléphone
mobile
non alors pas de la ministre parce que
mais du bon collaborateur en charge des
élus locaux donc son son numéro va
atterrir chez 36000 élus j'espère pour
lui que les 36000 vont pas l'appeler
mais je fais l'hypothèse qu'ils auront
une utilisation raisonnée de ce numéro
la justice comme on est comme on met
également la liste des dans le guide la
liste des référents préfectoraux on
espère que ils feront la première ligne
mais on travaille aussi très rapproché
avec les préfets qui eux-mêmes doivent
faire ces synthèses de différentes
politiques merci Madame Lamy j'en
profite pour vous remercier puisque
c'est ma dernière audition de ministre
voilà comme président de cette
commission donc merci pour les relations
que nous avons eu avec vous et
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
qui sont venus plancher ici dans cette
commission merci beaucoup et mes chers
collègues je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée voilà à lundi après-midi
n'oubliez pas